interrati su all'inter jones oggi video
super speciale vado a fare un po più
basse e quindi meno a scoppiare i
palloncini con gli ingredienti snel
dentro però al buio in più i palloncini
si illumineranno quindi sarà di punto
quinto al mondo e luminoso al buio e non
ride non riuscirà spero vicina
fantastico è più commentarne andrà
studia i palloncini con la forbice si
cela casinò che rispondono ovunque a
livello iniziale era di usare questi
palloncini quale striale kemalisti
praticamente in questi palloncini c'è un
alce dentro e ora proviamo ad attivarli
vediamo come funzionano c'è proprio un
led da abbiamo pensato che se la colla o
gli altri ingredienti toccano la cucina
legge potrebbe spegnersi o non so cosa
potrebbe succedere anche perché ci sono
delle batterie dentro cui vi potrebbe
essere il ricordo quindi ho deciso di
non stare qui stiamo a votare dei
palloncini normali dentro andrò a
mettere questi non so se sapete che cosa
sono ora ma da 31 punti vedete in
pratica sono queste stecchette che se
fai così li avrete forse già visti da
qualche parte comunque si attiva questa
sorta di liquido dentro è si illuminano
al buio dopo ovviamente
però chiudere finestra è tutto così
diventerà completamente buio e vedremo
che effetto fa voi faccia il primo
palloncino come s e poi se va tutto bene
andiamo a punto appare questo pochi
palloni bassi
la cena io fa la tengo chiuso e poi vado
piano piano ad infilarlo cercando di non
parcheggiare il palloncino ok ce l'ha
fatta e qua dentro ora non si vede
perché c'è molta luce però vado a
metterne anche un altro in questo caso
dello stesso colore e poi magari un
altro palo ci andiamo a mischiare i
colori così la luce sarà ancora più
forte
ecco cosa c'è su tre dentro compare
proprio commettere la colla spremuta
faccio allora apro la bolla che il
palloncino è arrotolato quindi non si
gonfia poi il patron metterlo
ok se ce l'ho fatta ora lo sbotto lo
scivolo praticamente un pittore con la
ue sta tutta col dentro però non
all'invito tutto il palloncino perché il
palloncino iniziato molto però c'è un
sacco di colla dentro quindi mi servono
ma poiché in aggressione che non
potevamo preparati ora non li vedete
luminoso perché ovviamente c'era dice
tra poco andiamo a chiudere tutto così
vedrete illuminarsi ma prima voglio
vedere come funzionano queste si
vedevano con la luce allora c'è scritto
che bisogna semplicemente si accesero
erano comunque vediamo se si vede che
bella modo simile tantissimo ma
sicuramente anche io si vedrà molto di
più vi piacciono un sacco di effetti
colorati
ok ecco l'altra questo rimane un
pubblicarlo
[Applauso]
ecco fatto allora abbiamo tutti i
palloncini pronti ora ad ottenere la
bacinella e forbice e vediamo un po come
si illuminano questi palloncini più di
brandi ma cosa dite che si pronunci
quindi mi raccomando lasciate un like a
questo video e realizziamo subito ok
ragazzi siete pronti a vedere come
silvio finali palloncini 3 2 1 guardate
che belli si minano il tacco e non so
come sia questo po più in basso non lo
hai fatto un po più baldanza buio non
potete vedere molto bene la mia faccia
perché vedere questo è rosso blu
poi c'è questo che mette lancio nel
mezzo giallo
questo è morta e giallo e satie pubblici
di colori entro
e poi se questo verde allora che prende
vedere come andare un po film e farà un
catino se voi non potete vedere una o
mette gli occhiali il basso ora per
proteggermi gli occhi caso mai avuto di
schizzi la colla negli occhi è un libro
che cambiava il primo perché non è mai
creare in poco perché il primo allora
non so se formare con steinmann con i
cugini dentro e reader come diventa
sotto curioso oppure tenerli il proprio
proviamo questo arancione siete pronti
palloncino dentro va bene per 2 1
[Musica]
no ragazzi non si bocca
riprovo ho sentito qualcosa che sono più
utilizzato comunque è una che l'altro
vede solamente un mix di colori adesso
guardate che bei colori
chissà come mai questo zaino noi
dedicato questo dentro per un po di
spinola la volontà produttivo
andiamo a me perfetto senza di voi
quindi probabilmente sono delle future
[Musica]
oddio vogliamo vedere in che stato io
ecco qua altri colori andiamo mischiarlo
tutto e vediamo come oggi sento le
palline sotto in piedi di due sono
volate do per tutto ok dev'essere
mancano solo 2 a breve un piano viviamo
come diventa vediamo questo rosso e sono
tantissimi 3 2 1
oggi io non capisco se qualcosa di me in
modo nuovo e rende capo il dolore ok
ragazzi
ora andiamo a scoppiare l'ultimo e poi
andiamo ha mischiato prima a luglio poi
una volta che si forma spero piuttosto
che siete pronti quello di no 32 fortuna
questa mi bastano un po di proviamo a 1
schiare adesso al buio vediamo se si
formano slime in mezzo anche a tutti
questi bellissimi colori allora aspetto
che si sta solidificando non ci credo
sta funzionando
vediamo se riesce ad anglo bar e anche i
colori però si per fortuna si sta
solidifica non so se riuscite a vedere
ma si sta formando sarà tipo lo strega
più assurdo che abbia mai fatto
anche perché ci sono i pezzi non ci
oggi è appunto supporto qua chissà
[Applauso]
quante lo potete come sta colori stanno
mischiando contro il brano è davvero uno
[Musica]
è un po complicato da mischiare con i
costi ovviamente però si sta ammalando
ragazzi c'è ragazzi ma che figata e non
so perché ma è troppo rilassante
vedrebbe poi si colora e mischiare e
tipo brembo slime lui però con le lucine
dentro i margini domani e l'inter hamas
calcola che mi mandava tutti i peccati a
mente però almeno riesco mischia
travaglio
ok troviamo invece le morbide
guardate questi colori ogni felicissimo
è troppo vinto e ancora ci vediamo se
riesco a fischiarlo meglio ovviamente è
molto più complicato al buio con queste
così tanti però l'effetto visivo e
questo è un palloncino mio figlio qui
anche consumo e molto asr anche è uscito
molto grande e più nomi che sono uscite
così grande ditemi qual è il colore per
le piace di più tra questi qua in mezzo
a me mi piace tantissimo questo rosa non
da questo scontro importantissimo per un
po di questi illuminano di più forse son
questi giochi converti questo continua a
non rischiarlo
io non capisco come
sinceramente però qualche problema che
guardate che colora quando faccio il
cooking facebook di tanti colori
[Musica]
bellissimo guardate a seconda di dove
facendo un pò king proviamo comune
[Applauso]
non voglio più accendere la luce è
troppo rilassate meglio che mandare a
giocare con questo schermo multi color
[Musica]
che sono un sacco di questi colori
se non vi chiamo i colori ma erano ok
ragazzi siete pronti a paterno con le
luci accese
ora non lo è lucida finestra noi andiamo
ad aprire la finestra e vediamo quanto
ti fa vedere come con la luce 3 2 1 o
mio dio ma la mente diverto
innanzi tutto è bianco nonostante io
abbia usato la colla trasparente ma
perché ho anche messo il gel da barba e
poi non si vedono per niente i colori
però si vedono le palline colorate si
vedono un pochino i colori sembra un po
un bear dei cake ed è uscito un mezzo
flop
praticamente e cordate ma il
concentramento è diverso con la ricetta
ora vediamo che addio guardate il tavolo
tutte le bambine
oggi vediamo se fortunatamente non mi
sono macchiate incredibile poi devo fare
un signore abbastanza per vedere prima
dove schizzato la schiuma da barba
perché un visto che la schiuma da barba
a chi va da qualche parte siete pronti a
cederla
[Musica]
oddio spero che non sia rovinato per
sempre fanno davvero bene e ora siete
pronti 3 2 1
guardate che meraviglia bellissimo il
buio per istante io davvero stare il
fatto nelle ore a giocare ora sono
questa stringa perché questa voce è
fantastico poi a seconda di come lo
rischio secondo me questo è uno slime
molto sm rt sicuramente aderiscono che
sono molto smr fisicamente e torniamo
alla luce in 3 2 1 limita aperte per il
sito posto slime con l'esperimento
pazzesco con il pop in valute al buio
primi commenti quali altri esperimenti o
sfide quali spazi e volete che spazia
scrivetemi tutte le cose
è il migliore quello che interessano
fioca trova all'estero un cuoricino
e mi raccomando facciamo a raggiungere
questo video 10.000 nice così farò altri
esperimenti infatti e ditemi che ne
pensate di questo fantastico straaten
luminoso interattivo e io lo farò magari
me lo metto tipo incamera il potere di
fatto da colorata l'unica cosa che mi
dispiace che queste lucine mi sa che non
durano tantissimo telecontrollare nostro
futuro
però insomma non fa sempre tutto quindi
prima o poi si scaricherà per ogni
mostra che volete ad rivederlo e risulti
ricchissimo ristori costanzi basta che
guardate questo video
ora però sto qua 4 castellini non potete
cliccare se volete vedere altri di
challenge ultimates live altri video
divertenti
cliccate pure in una di queste è buona
visione